c'est officiel après le Mali et le
Burkina Faso la France quitte le Niger
Emmanuel Macron l'a annoncé dimanche
soir l'ambassadeur français quittera le
pays dans les prochaines heures et les
1500 soldats français déployés sur la
base aérienne de Niamey auront plié
bagages d'ici à la fin de l'année c'est
un nouveau revers pour Paris un peu plus
de 2 mois après le coup d'État qui a
renversé le président nigérien mohamed
Bazoum la France a ainsi cédé après
plusieurs semaines de fer alors qu'elle
avait dans un premier temps refusé de se
plier à l'autorité illégitime de la
jante militaire au pouvoir les forces
françaises avaient été déployées dès
2014 dans le cadre de l'opération
antiterroriste barkham et leur retrait
représente un véritable défi logistique
Mirage 2000 drone Ripper mais aussi Fab
et griffon en quelques mois tout un
arsenal doit être évacué par voie
terrestre et aérienne si la plupart sera
cheminée jusqu'au port du Golfe de
Guinée comme au Bénin par exemple une
partie des structures peu stratégiques
pourraient être laissées sur place nous
nous concerterons avec les puccistes
parce que nous voulons que ça se fasse
dans le calme depuis 2021 la région a
été le théâtre d'une série de coups
d'État qui a porté au pouvoir des jantes
militaires hostiles à Paris et proche de
la Russie Emmanuel Macron avait espéré
faire du partenariat franco-nigérien le
modèle d'une relation renouvelée avec
l'Afrique après la fin de l'opération
barkham en 2022 mais le putsch militaire
du Niger fait désormais craint d'une
perte durable de l'influence française
dans la bande saelo saharienne pour le
président de la République le retrait
français et surtout une mauvaise
nouvelle pour la sécurité du Sahel ou la
formation d'un califat territorial n'est
désormais plus à exclure